[Music]
i'm deborah adam simmons
executive editor for history and culture
at national geographic
you're listening to in conversation a
special episode exploring black history
and culture
[Music]
hey deborah welcome to overheard hi amy
thanks it's fun to be here i'm excited
to share some of the great interviews
that you
peter and the team have done in the past
year yeah i'm so
glad that you've taken the time to be
here so thank you for that so who are we
highlighting as part of this special
episode
we went back in the archives and
actually in most cases
into your raw tape and pulled out
interviews you've had with explorer tara
roberts
computer scientist gloria washington and
photographer rudy roy
so today we'll be hearing from all three
of them
through their work across maritime
archaeology artificial intelligence and
photojournalism
tara gloria and reddy are determined to
reframe black history and culture
i was in awe of tara it was
amazing to hear about the the path that
she's taken through life
and the amazing journey she had you know
finding
finding diving with a purpose and her
and her mission to reframe the story of
africans in the americas
great so let's begin with national
geographic storytelling fellow tara
roberts and her conversation with you
amy from this past fall
tara is documenting the efforts of black
scuba divers and archaeologists to find
the lost wrecks of ships that carried
enslaved people from
africa to the americas this is really
critical work
and we are excited to hear what she has
to say
more after this
i was talking to my mom before this call
and my mother is a huge
like she's so concerned with um the
history of our family
and she's the one in the family who's
you know doing the family tree and
trying to trace
our roots back and my family
is able to trace back to my
great it's my great
great grandfather so my grandfather's
grandparents but that's as far back as
we can go
and we do have pictures of them which is
great
and i actually remember seeing my
great grandfather's
name and my great grandmother's name
listed on
a ledger for a plantation
in north carolina i was
using ancestry.com and my cousin had
done some research and we saw
my great great grandfather and
grandmother's
names and that's just like oh
that that hit you in in so many places
but that's as far as we can go back i
know nothing else
so
looking at this history
past these shores
it opens up something for me it gives me
access into a part of my past
that i didn't have before
and that's exciting to me like slavery
is not the start of our story
but according to the history books it is
that's where everything starts and
there's this misunderstanding
of africa i don't even know what's like
actually meant by the word africa like
it's
it's this huge place with 52 or
don't quote me on that is it 52 or 54
countries
it's a lot of a lot of countries with
really distinct and different
traditions and legacies and cultures
but it all gets mashed together into
this one thing
i think that this this access
that the shipwrecks give us
[Music]
opens up an opportunity
to distinguish um
to deepen
[Music]
to further understand who i am and where
i come from
and to do that outside of a frame
that i've been given as a black american
in this country
so how how has your your work
recreated that frame for you where would
you put the beginning
well not there i think that's clear
i mean i think it's it's opened up far
more questions
so i'll say this um i also did
ancestry.com for my
uh to see where my dna is traced from
and quite a bit of it is traced
from west africa
but when you look at where the migratory
patterns are it's like some of my
ancestry comes from the bantu people
who were throughout southern africa
as well so when i go to mozambique like
is it possible that maybe some of my
ancestry
is there as well i don't know
but maybe so i feel like i have
way more questions and more places to
look
more places to think and that feels
really exciting to me
so i don't have an answer yet
about like completely
what specifically a ship did for me or
or how i see things differently
but i just it feels like there's an
expanse now
that wasn't there before like it was a
wall and it was a closed door and it was
this sad
um wall that you just didn't want to be
a part of you didn't want to
touch it but now there's like an open
expanse and there's like there's sadness
in the expanse and there's some pain
but there's there's a lot more
it's almost like in your particular
instance
you know that that wall started at that
ledger in north carolina
you know that's where it stopped and
then you have
i'm in my mind i'm just seeing like the
wrecks almost coming out of the water
and like from flooding that wall away
you know
oh i love that that's a beautiful
image i love that because that's the
that's washing away all of that
that inability to access the other you
know that you feel unknowable
but it's like you can get more of your
you know
get more of your feet wet in the story
or i'm not going to strain the water
metaphor anymore but
um i'm sorry i'm crying a little bit um
this is just so moving um
so um
what do you think needs to happen for
more
of these you know of the racks to be
found and identified
yeah it's a great question um
[Music]
yeah i mean i guess there's an obvious
answer oh more divers
more more funding more
opportunities to participate in the work
but i actually think i'll back up from
that and i'll say i think
really what's necessary and then all
kinds of things lead from that
but i think what's necessary
is recognition
that this history matters more people
understanding that there is a
bigger narrative to be told that this
work is
important um
and that it matters for a huge part of
the u.s population
and also that this story is not just a
black people story
like this is part of all of our history
and that
there's not um
a focused effort to like discover it
is insane i was thinking the other day
about how many stories and how much
work was done or
devoted to documenting
the titanic like there's so many stories
about the titanic
and there are stories from cultures
all around the world like it's a story
that has captured people's imaginations
and it is it's a great story like it's a
tragic story
it's a moving story like that story was
important
so how does this story get that kind of
[Music]
weight where then
resources
are dedicated to it you know again it
could
it could be like 650 000 people whose
lives were lost
[Music]
there's this really interesting moment
in time right now
where things that have been hidden in
the shadows
are coming out like people are seeing
things that they hadn't seen before
and there's an openness to engage with
these things
um and i think that there's an openness
to engage
with history in a way that
has not been possible before
so what do i think needs to happen to
move
this work forward is more of that
more people realizing that this
is so important
and when that happens like all the
levers change
there are all sorts of creative ways to
approach this and
more technology can be used um
to find wrecks more work can be done
to track down where the ships are where
they might be
and what their histories are more divers
can get trained
like then a lot can happen but there has
to be a will
to find this history and a will to tell
the story differently
so that's what we need to move forward
that's national geographic storytelling
fellow tara roberts speaking with
overheard's amy briggs
it was such an incredible conversation
and i'm so excited that we got to
feature more of it than we did in in her
episode
and tara will be posting updates about
her travels on instagram and facebook
you can find those at stories from the
depths
you can also find out more about diving
with a purpose by listening to our
overheard podcast
episode the search for history's lost
slave ships
[Music]
so debra who do we have next next we
bring you a conversation between
computer scientist gloria washington and
brian gutierrez
guest host of overheard
gloria washington runs the effective
biometrics labs at howard university in
washington d.c
she's an expert on emotional artificial
intelligence
i'm going to have to take notes on this
part because i'm not i don't even know
anything about natural emotional
intelligence
[Music]
well let's listen
uh gloria the first thing we usually
start with is a
quick introduction you know could you
please introduce yourself who are you
and what do you do i'm gloria washington
and i run the effective biometrics lab
at howard university
and that's effective with an a yes it
means emotional
in my lab we look at facial expressions
we look at
ears we look at physiological
information
like heart rate heart rate variability
that tells us all kind of information
about
a person's emotional state and we can
make inferences
and conclusions if this information is
fed in the ai
to tell us if a person is frustrated
happy sad
neutral disgusted but it helps us tune
and actually create software systems
that think
more smartly about the human what does
it mean for
artificial intelligence to be emotional
like those are not two
adjectives i would put together in
normal speech
what does that mean yeah so when you get
into
making um any type of software we often
forget that the software is supposed to
serve the human and not the other way
around
and sometimes that can lead to
frustration it can lead to
you know whole groups of people having a
horrible disposition about using
technology
and so my area is interested in
understanding how do we make these
interactions with computers more
positive how do we make them more happy
here and how do we use the emotional
information that you can gather from a
human
to actually make our software
applications better
[Music]
i wonder if we could zoom out for a
minute and ask some like general ai
questions
uh you know artificial intelligence kind
of means a lot of different things to a
lot of different people
how do you define artificial
intelligence what makes
that computer intelligent whoa
so i think fine definition is probably
a little bit different from the
traditional computer scientists
so i think of artificial intelligence as
a helper
it's a helpful application that allows
me to triage
and presents information in a unique
and easily digestible way so that i can
do my job better
whatever that job is some traditional
computer scientists would go
almost to a micro level where they talk
about
the actual deep learning algorithms
where you get down to
the connections in the neural network
but me
i like to keep it higher level because i
truly think it is
and when we think of artificial
intelligence we think that the machine
should be a helper to
us not take over our job it should only
supplement
triage recommend and then we the human
can act on in a more intelligent way
to actually go about our day
so i was wondering if you could kind of
like talk me through your day as a data
scientist
and and what are kind of like some of
the sounds you might hear
as you're doing your job as a data
scientist
at howard i work with a lot
of undergraduate students and they see
things totally different
from the way that i see things
so it's a lot of questions it's a lot of
well why is this technique producing
this kind of data
i think it's flawed and um
a lot of young people now care about
issues that are important to them like
feminism
criminal justice police justice black
lives matter stuff like that
and they want to work on those kind of
problems so the questions that they
would have is well
why aren't i seeing kind of technologies
that are catered towards me
and why aren't you know these kind of
things
important so i'm feeling a lot of
questions
like that from my undergraduate research
students i have about 15 that i work
with
and at least my philosophy is
if they're if interested in learning
more why not
expose them as early as possible to it
even if they don't know all of the
intricacies behind the scenes but
they're learning
and so when they're learning they're
asking me those kind of questions of
why why did it even take
you know for george floyd for people to
start to care
or you know and then that feeds into
technology well i would ask them a
question well
you're a computer scientist what would
you do what technology
would you build or what company would
you start to be able to address that
problem in your community
you seem like a really like fight fire
with fire kind of woman like
uh we have these issues with ai
technology we're gonna build our own ai
to counteract it in these ways well i
think it's important
and and i recognize this now when i see
how dependent i am on certain things and
i'm like
if we think about how many burger shops
there are
why can't we have 50 million burger
shops for one ai
technique built by one company no there
should be 50
million a.i techniques and the pizza the
pie
is large and we can contribute to that
so i want students to know that
you can get a piece of that pie yourself
and do not be afraid to
get it why is diversity in a.i
important diversity in ai
is important because i think sometimes
we are trapped in our own heads and
trapped in the problems that are
important to us
as humans and we may not recognize a
problem
from a different perspective so having
diverse people
at the table or who are actually coding
the algorithms behind the scenes will
expose
the flaws that may come up with the
algorithm
how do you know if a data set is diverse
you know my impression is that there's
like millions and millions of images
you know maybe you you know i could look
at maybe 100 images in a day
how do you know if there's an issue
well for me um
i did a postdoc in this and i had no
choice but to look at these um databases
of millions of images
where my entire day was looking through
these databases to determine how diverse
they were
but what i had to do was search through
these databases how many
and they usually tell you how many men
how many women
how many um black people white people
but then it kind of ends there
it doesn't even talk about ethnicity
like
within the individuals because when you
think about it
a lot of the college students fill out a
form
and this form information and it's just
like what's your age what you're raised
that kind of thing gender and so i had
no choice but to look through most of
these databases and there are millions
of images so there needs to be um
people behind the scenes that can
actually say hey you know
let's uh retune our system or retrain
our system to get a better model based
off of this database because it has
this many men or this many women and
it's more diverse than the average
database that we would
get just starting out
i think this is also a really cool
opportunity to let people know about
research that's being done by black ai
researchers
i wonder if you could tell me um you
know what are some of the recent
innovations that
have been happening in that space what
are some of the new ais that are being
designed by black researchers that
people should know that
i would say black ai specialists are
starting to work in areas that are
important to their communities
so there are apps now that will find you
a barbershop
but it finds you a barber shop based off
of your input and it learns from you
if you go to that actual barber shop so
we're starting to think of problems that
are specific to our community
like i can't find this hair product
or i can't find stuff for me or i have
diabetes
and i have a specific health application
that
is only you know for african americans
like there are products that being
developed for our specific
community yeah that makes sense yeah
and i wonder how you sort of situate
yourself in this history of
african-american scientists working in
the united states like the hidden
figures
that was an awesome movie i really
enjoyed watching it but i
i think they truly are hidden figures in
the sense that i had no idea they
existed before
the movie came out i i was wondering if
you could you know
kind of put your work in the context of
this history
of female scientists female
african-american scientists
and and what that history means to you
when i sort of think of of myself in the
history of african-american
computer sciences even that are
african-american not even female when we
think of it so
in the time of hidden figures there were
many women black coders who were leading
the scene
um whatever happened after
the black programmers or coders
were phased out diversity and computer
science just plummeted
i kind of fit in after them and kind of
see myself as
taking up the struggle of everything
that they had at that moment that they
probably couldn't voice
because if you even think about getting
in the door of being
working at nasa you probably have to be
quiet about a lot
you couldn't express the particular kind
of things that were most important to
you
you did your job you were a programmer
you're working behind the scene working
on these math problems
but the kind of issues that i'm focusing
on are issues
that i take exactly what they were doing
with programming working on mathematical
issues
image processing issues but i'm
tailoring it for my community
so i think of like using all the
background and all of the information
and struggle that they
went through but tailoring it now we're
having the actual
voice to be able to say i want to work
on the problems that are important to my
community
and when i think of from the perspective
of being in emotional artificial
intelligence
there are not a lot of black women who
are in this area
so i'm also writing the background and
all of the history
and all of the problems and challenges
and opportunities that she had
in this emotional ai space and
then tailoring it also for working on
things that are important to the black
community like
hair products black lives matter
also another thing that i'm interested
in getting into is microaggression
research
of how we think of of
people who are microaggressed on a daily
basis of how
microaggressions feed into our everyday
life and if we have technology now that
can tell us
when we've accidentally offended
individuals
maybe we can start to get better and
maybe we can learn
in these diversity and inclusion
training seminars
what we have done wrong like on a yearly
basis kind of thing and improve our
speech
like we do a lot of that now and
i put my foot in my mouth a lot and i
think of
why can't there be technology that helps
me not put my foot in my mouth but it
makes me get better
when i think of that kind of space of
how i fit in i'm working on
novel things that are important to the
black and brown communities
gloria washington will be featured in an
upcoming overheard episode
on the battle for the soul of artificial
intelligence you can follow her work on
social media
at dr glow wash i will definitely be
checking that out not only because
it's a fascinating topic but that
upcoming episode
is our producer brian gutierrez's first
time hosting
so it's his official debut
and finally amy we bring you a
conversation between national geographic
photographer and storytelling fellow
reddy roy
and peter gwynne your co-host here at
overheard
so deborah i hear you've worked with
ready before rudy roy's first assignment
for national geographic was to
photograph people donating artifacts to
the smithsonian's national museum of
african american history and culture in
washington dc
he also did a fantastic job
photographing historically black
colleges
in atlanta and this past summer his work
on the protests was really
outstanding let's listen
it was beautiful to me it was beautiful
to travel around the country
photographing
nat turner's great great great great
grandson and seen a history
that is not in our history books it's
not told anywhere
photographing a sign that says blackett
signposts and knowing that
this signpost was was erected
to instill fear in any
other people of african descent
who was working in in virginia for free
from having another insurrection and
that's why that sign was there
it said blackhead signpost still
in virginia wow every story that i've
done for for geographic
everyone i followed that up with the
race issue
which made me sit at
morehouse university and and look at the
next generation of of our black leaders
and see the pros and cons
of of what it means to to grow up in a
country that does not
feed you its history i've learned
i've learned more from these than i
think i've been able to
like put into these pictures
um these are actually the histories of
the history that i've
brought back to my to my sons
to the effect that when my son was given
this
this assignment to write on a civil
rights leader
he said to his teacher that he preferred
to write about his father
because that's where he gets his history
from wow
so these stories
have been more than just stories for me
they have been pages in a history that
has not been written yet because it's
not a part of our curriculum
and it's not in our history books
so i know that you teach um or you have
taught at new york university
what's the first thing you tell a
student who who wants to be a
photographer
why do you want to photograph black
content
is that important to you no first i
usually ask
how many of you would like to photograph
black content usually the whole class
and i say this is like a mixed class of
like all right
it's usually it's usually 80
90 white of a class of 13 kids
two to four black kids so i usually go
why
why what makes you think that you're
qualified
and they look at me like and so i'd say
do you know who emmett till his
is do you know who ida b wells is do you
know
what jim crow did and i and
and and i would tell these stories
because i wanted them to get to the
place where
i was assigned to do a story covering
the gangster disciples in chicago and
the black disciples in chicago
and at the end of the assignment time
magazine asked me why is it that when we
send you to go to a story
about gangsters you didn't bring back
gangsters
and i would say because i didn't see any
gangster
i said i saw father's brothers nephews
you know sons cousins
but if the gangster turned up i would
photograph them
but in that space i see humans
and i said the only way you can get to
that space is if you understand
the history that has dictated how these
people live their lives
if you can understand that you see the
story differently
[Music]
i did a workshop with uh an editor
in in new york and while i'm in there
some
a girl from lithuania was asked why she
wanted to be a part of the workshop and
she said because i want to photograph
um the ghettos of bits of um
to get to the bronzeville brownsville
and we go ghettos of bronzeville she
said yes i want to go to the ghettos of
brownsville
and the next day so i was just i was i
lost it
but the next day she went to brownsville
and all she came back with
crack valves and and and and people who
are smoking crack
and i never went back to the workshop i
couldn't
because for me it was not my job to tell
her that what she's doing
is the stereotypical story
and i did not see the editor doing it
so in jamaica we say you don't go to a
man's house
and criticize him you leave
that's what i did
[Music]
one of the things about your photography
that i'm so struck by is that
yours especially known for your
portraits
your portraits have this gravity to them
it feels like i'm passing by a planet
like jupiter that has this really strong
gravity
and it pulls me into the picture and how
do you
create that what is it that you do to
create a picture that pulls a reader in
like that
if there's a thing because you know i i
also believe that
and this is gonna sound corny but
there's there's
to everything in life whether it's
whichever it's on the yin or the yang
there's a spiritual element to
everything
it's how you use it um
for instance there are certain words i
don't use i don't use
the word like i'm going to photograph
my subject i don't use that word because
i believe that it creates
hierarchy i also
when i'm going to do a story or i'm
going to photograph a portrait
i like to find a space where i can
connect
even before i start taking pictures and
that connection
is like i don't know if you you saw
the um avatar yeah is it the avatar
um the james cameron film the james
cameron film where
they would pull their hair and touch
each other
and that's how they join
your job i think is to find a way to
join with that person
so that they can give you something
that's deeper than the superficial
and my the one way that i find
that gets to that place is when they
know
that you understand
and whether it is giving them
the story that you have been through
this before or
you have seen it photograph it on you
you kind of
you kind of have an idea
of of where we are and never
never pretending to like to fully
understand
but leave in space so that they fill in
the gaps for you
and it is in that space then filling the
gaps that
the authenticity comes up but it's
always
joining spirits it's always for me
never feeling like i'm coming here to
take something
but i'm coming there to give you
something in order
to get something there's always an
exchange
more after this
[Music]
you can follow rudy roy on instagram
ready roy
and learn more about his project when
living as a protest by listening to the
overheard
episode can you hear the reggae in my
photographs
it's been so great hearing from these
amazing explorers scientists and
photographers
having their perspective and insight on
all these different issues has just been
eye-opening
absolutely also be sure to visit our
race in america hub at natgeo.com
where we chronicle the human journey of
racial ethnic and religious groups
across the united states
there you'll find our story exploring
the history of black military service
and the impact on families
plus we revisit historically black
colleges and universities
while exploring the risk many face to
keep their doors
open and for subscribers check out
national geographic magazine's story
about how reddy's jamaican roots
ignited his passion for social justice
that's in the show notes right there on
your podcast app
in conversation that national geographic
is produced by davar ardellin
executive producer of audio together
with sound designer and engineer
hans dale sue musical composition comes
from
scott dudley corey english and martyrius
hersey of push.audio
special thanks to overheard's carla
wills eli chen peter gwynne
brian gutierrez laura sim jacob pinter
and nachio's drew
jones our fact checker is michelle
harris
our copy editor is amy kolczak the
national geographic society
committed to illuminating and protecting
the wonder of our world
funds the work of national geographic
explorer tara roberts
and national geographic explorer and
photographer
freddie roy this podcast is a production
of national geographic partners
whitney johnson is the director of
visuals and immersive experiences
susan goldberg is national geographic's
editorial director
i'm your host deborah adam simmons
and i'm amy briggs see you next time
[Music]
you